y comienzo preguntándole por la reacción
o cuál es su opinión después de los
hechos de violencia vividos ayer en el
país principalmente en la región del
valle del cauca
muy buenos días y obviamente la posición
del gobierno la posición del presidente
iván duque es la de rechazo a todas las
formas de violencia que se pueden haber
presentado con ocasión de las
manifestaciones tanto las que se dieron
ayer como las que se han venido dando
durante estos días sigamos hablando de
eso porque colombia llevo un mes en los
titulares internacionales precisamente
por las denuncias de violencia policial
organizaciones de derechos hablan de
3.400 casos de violencia y vinculan 43
muertes a enfrentamientos con la fuerza
pública porque el gobierno no ha
permitido la entrada de la sede h de
verificar lo que está pasando y también
le pregunto por una sensación que hay
entre algunos sectores de la población
de falta de contundencia del presidente
en la condena de la muerte de
manifestantes
esa es una falta es una percepción como
usted lo lo ha expresado el presidente
ha sido absolutamente claro y el
gobierno de colombia es absolutamente
claro en que todas las formas de
violencia
son ilegales esto abarca tanto las que
se causan por parte de quienes
pretendiendo que están expresando su
inconformidad lo que hacen es que causan
afectaciones a los bienes públicos
afectaciones a las condiciones de los
colombianos
pero también las que se dan cuando en el
ejercicio de la función pública se
cometan excesos
el presidente ha sido igualmente claro
en que unas y otras son son ilegales y
qué pasa con la sede h porque no se
permite el ingreso
esa es una también es una imprecisión la
vicepresidente estuvo en washington y
señaló que debe realizarse la audiencia
que corresponde a ese procedimiento y
que una vez que se realice la audiencia
ellos estarán en colombia
bueno y entonces le pregunto más
exactamente en su trabajo en qué van las
negociaciones con el comité del paro es
cierto que hay optimismo para lograr
algún tipo de acuerdo en los próximos
días
en la forma como como ha venido esto el
comité nacional del del padre presentó
un listado de los temas que ellos
quieren que se traten que denominaron
el pliego de urgencia como requisito
para que nos pudiéramos sentar a en esa
mesa de negociación a ellos les pareció
que debía darse un acuerdo sobre
precisamente las garantías para la
protesta en eso hemos venido trabajando
intensamente en jornadas de hasta 18
días en el de horas al día y llegamos a
un texto en el que ambas partes
estábamos
tranquilos ya en lo que tiene que vivir
con las garantías a quienes se están
manifestando desde el 18
nosotros les pusimos de presente que
deberían también darse garantías a los
45 millones de colombianos que no están
en el enlace de enlace de
manifestaciones esto en la manera de
condenar de manera definitiva y absoluta
los bloqueos que se están presentando en
un número plural de las regiones de
colombia en esa medida la posición del
gobierno es que esos bloqueos son
ilegales causan muchos problemas para
nuestros colombianos causan que no haya
suficiencia de salud que no haya la
posibilidad de circular los alimentos
que se afecten el empleo que se afecten
a nuestros emprendedores y en esa medida
e indicamos que estamos pendientes de
que mañana podamos acordar que las dos
partes condenan los los bloqueos si eso
sucede
estamos inclusive presentando una
metodología de trabajo para que podamos
iniciar el análisis de los temas de
fondo inmediatamente bueno y ya
aparecieron muy rápidamente hablemos
sobre el discurso de ayer del presidente
iván duque más militarización le
pregunta o no aumentaría la polarización
que existe en el país y que se ve en
todas partes y qué decir de las
afirmaciones de la oposición que asegura
que el gobierno está dilatando el paro
para derechizar el voto en un año
y ninguna de las dos cosas son precisas
es importante que se entienda lo que
ocurrió y ha venido ocurriendo en el
valle del cauca y como consecuencia de
la actividad de personas que de ninguna
manera se pueden caracterizar como que
están protestando pacíficamente